within the space of two-in-a-bit games
and a tie-in comic the last of us
franchise covers quite a lot of ground
from its heartbreaking opening moments
all the way through to part two's epic
tale of revenge there's a huge amount of
twists and turns across its extensive
timeline that spans well over 25 years
and with the remake of the first game
out alongside a new tv adaptation what
better time to reacquaint yourself with
naughty dog's stellar survival series hi
my name's adam and this is the complete
timeline of the last of us franchise
[Music]
the last of us's timeline kicks off its
post-apocalyptic tale in the only way it
knows how full on heartbreak and we're
only a minute into our timeline the year
is 2013 and it's joel miller's birthday
after coming home from a long shift at
work he flops onto the sofa with his
daughter sarah who surprises him with
his birthday gift the celebrations it's
safe to say do not last long later that
night a host of mysterious events take
place namely the overly aggressive tone
of joel and sarah's neighbours and i
thought my neighbours were bad i'm just
joking stephen and eileen you guys are
great the cause of this hyperaggression
is a new found fungal parasite known as
cordyceps terrifyingly a real thing look
it up which has kickstarted a full-on
pandemic of mushroom zombies around the
world closer to home cordyceps is
ripping through the population of austin
texas where joel sarah and joel's
brother tommy live the trio attempt to
evacuate town but get caught up in the
ensuing chaos which they managed to
escape by the skin of their teeth just
as they think they're in the clear they
bump into the army hooray you might
think not hooray trying to contain the
austin outbreak the lone soldier joel
and sarah run into is tasked with
eliminating any escapees and he takes
fire somehow joel manages to survive and
just as the soldier is going in for the
kill tommy pops in with a headshot
tragically though sarah is fatally shot
and dies in the hands of her grieving
father
don't
welcome to the world of the last of us
pals buckle up
[Music]
fast forward 19 years and the world has
descended into absolute anarchy
governments have fallen and people are
pretty much surviving all on their own
save for the odd quarantine zone dotted
around various cities in the us we meet
13 year old ellie in one of these qz's
in the city of boston in the tie-in
comic american dreams having been
bounced around various schools she's
wound up in this military boarding
college where she meets the similarly
rebellious teen riley the pair strike up
an unlikely friendship which sees them
break out of the school and explore the
city at night their misadventures take
in a horse ride around the local mall a
near fatal encounter with one of the
infected what the last of us is brand of
zombies are known as before finally
bumping into a group of renegade freedom
fighters known as the fireflies when one
of the fireflies recognizes ellie the
pair get embroiled in a fight for
survival after they get into a firefight
with some local smugglers after gunning
the smugglers down the woman who
recognizes ellie reveals herself to be
marlene the head of the fireflies and
she tells ellie to head back to school
as it's the safest place for her but not
before handing her a letter and a knife
that belonged to her mum
a year later we catch back up with ellie
and riley in the dlc story expansion
left behind riley is no longer at the
military boarding school but she returns
to visit ellie in the middle of the
night with news that she's joined the
fireflies the pair head to the same mall
they visited in american dreams and goof
about at the arcade angel knives throws
her fists in the air
you
win riley reveals that she's leaving
with the fireflies for another city
which naturally upsets ellie who
harbours feelings for her and not
wanting to leave things on a sour note
ellie follows riley deeper into the mall
the pair argue over the shite hand
they've both been dealt in life and
riley diffuses the argument with the
welcome addition of a pair of super
soakers which to be fair is a top tier
tactic for stopping a squabble i'm gonna
destroy you
and then we'll talk this bittersweet
reunion reaches a musical crescendo when
riley plays one of ellie's cassettes on
a store sound system the pair dance and
ultimately share a kiss and in this
happy moment ellie pleads for riley not
to go and she agrees but this love is
sadly of the doomed variety as the music
has attracted the unwanted attention of
a horde of infected who chase ellie and
riley down the pair managed to survive
but taking stock after the fight they
realize they've both been bitten and are
doomed to turn into infected themselves
and left behind ends with them both
accepting their fate waiting for the end
or as riley puts it be all poetic and
just lose our minds together
but as we find out later that summer
that's not exactly how things play out
but before i get ahead of myself let's
reacquaint ourselves with our good pal
and super fun guy joel time and stress
have naturally done quite the number on
the grizzled texan lad and he's found
himself getting by smuggling in the city
of boston with his partner in crime tess
a gun run gone wrong brings them into
the path of queen firefly marlene and
she tells them she can set their gun run
right if they help her smuggle something
out of the city and by something she
means our rebellious friend ellie who
survived the certain death of turning
into a snarling mushroom zombie for
reasons that aren't made clear at this
stage they're made abundantly clear
though when joel tess and ellie get
caught by a group of soldiers who test
them for infection when ellie's test
comes back as positive for cordyceps she
reveals that it's been three weeks since
she was bitten and well that she might
just be immune it's three weeks i swear
the weight of responsibility for this
new crusade for the fireflies crashes
down on joel but he agrees to escort
ellie out of the city naturally things
go south when they get to the drop zone
to find all the fireflies dead no no no
oh and even further south when tess
reveals that she's been bitten too oops
right so when the military turns up tess
sacrifices herself to allow joel and
ellie to escape boston and so our
dynamic duo begin their long odyssey to
find more fireflies to test ellie for a
potential cure
[Music]
after a rather less than fortuitous
stopover in a town run by a salty old
fish called bill they secure a car and
start heading west towards the city of
pittsburgh on the way joel and ellie
start bonding around the varied topics
of comic books country music and um
porn how the hell would he even walk
around with that thing get rid of that
hold your horses i want to see what all
the fuss is about their bonding session
gets rudely interrupted by a den of
smugglers though who snare them in a
trap in the center of pittsburgh without
a car the pair have to make it across
the fortified city center on foot which
they eventually do with the help from
another pair of survivors called henry
and sam the quartet make it to the
outskirts of town by a particularly
nightmarish section of the nearby
waterways and as they think they're in
the clear they're attacked from both
sides by infected and smugglers and in
the chaos poor little sam is bitten the
next morning he attacks ellie and his
brother henry is the one to put him down
and totally distraught henry then turns
the gun on himself and damn this
franchise really knows how to strike
when your guard is down
[Music]
after the all-out carnage of summer the
pair continue their journey west and
eventually reach the outskirts of
jackson wyoming why are they here you
ask well it turns out that joel's
younger brother tommy has settled in the
area and lo and behold the pair bumped
right into him at a giant hydroelectric
dam holy [ __ ]
how you doing baby brother with tommy's
history with the fireflies joel hopes
that his little bro can take ellie to
the nearest troop of freedom fires tommy
doesn't take too kindly to being his
brother's errand boy though but their
argument is cut short by an attack from
bandits on the dam after the fighting is
done ellie makes a run for it on her own
sick of being the center of everyone's
problems joel and tommy follow in
pursuit and track her down to a
farmhouse in the woods where ellie pours
her heart out to joel sad at being left
alone again by someone she trusts don't
tell me that i would be safer with
someone else because the truth is i
would just be more scared joel takes
this to heart and as they're planning to
head west to the university of eastern
colorado to find the fireflies he takes
over from tommy the pair make it to the
university and locate the fireflies base
of operations but surprise surprise
they're not there from a dictaphone
recording they learn that the scientists
have up sticks and travelled even
further west to the heady heights of
salt lake city but before they can get
on their way bandits attack yet again
and in the fight joel is mortally
wounded leaving ellie to fend for
herself and save his lumberjack ass
yeah this franchise continues to turn
the screws
with winter's chill settling in ellie
and joel hole up at a nearby shopping
mall as we see in the present day
sections have left behind ellie sneaks
and scours her way around infected and
human foes alike and eventually secures
some much-needed medicine for joel
before the pair can continue their
journey to be honest they don't make it
that far which is a surprise to
absolutely no one because a 13 year old
girl is having to look after a grown man
with a hole in his stomach hunkered down
in a small town in the mountains ellie
takes to hunting to survive and while
doing so bumps into this lad david who
spoilers is an absolute wrongin but
we'll get to that shortly that's right
before his inevitable heel turn ellie
trades the deer she's just killed for
medical supplies to help jal after
surviving an attack from a huge hoard of
infected david shows his true colours by
hunting down and kidnapping ellie from
outside her hideout turns out david is
even more of wrong than first thought as
ellie discovers that he and his lads are
actual cannibals joel eventually wakes
up from his winter hibernation and you
know the damage done by his injuries but
whatever tortures a pair of david's crew
and discovers where ellie is being held
he hightails it over to ellie and finds
the place up in smoke courtesy of ellie
who's halfway through rearranging
david's face with a machete as you do
and if he wasn't a cannibalistic man man
i might feel sorry for him
[Music]
so you might have noticed that this
century actually has a full date and
that's because well it's kind of a big
deal in the franchise's timeline for
starters joel and ellie encounter actual
giraffes ah look at these cute lads
after the horrible winter they've had
they really deserve this moment imo but
on a more serious night the pair finally
made their way to salt lake city where
the firefly said they were setting up
shopping joel and ellie eventually
crossed past with the fireflies
themselves and they're not the kindly
planet-saving scientists you might have
been expecting
they knock joel out and grab ellie to
start experimenting on her and oh uh
marlene is here as well and it's her
that informs joel of the severity of the
situation the cold hard sobering truth
of the matter is this ellie could be the
key to saving humanity but she'll likely
die in the process because you know
cutting her brain open for a cure and
all
joel isn't having any of that though you
see over the course of their long
odyssey across the u.s he's come to see
ellie as a surrogate daughter a near
replacement for his actual daughter
sarah he tears through the firefly base
of operations like a man possessed and
he eventually makes it to the room where
they're operating on ellie in a blind
fit of rage he shoots the doctor working
on ellie in cold blood i won't let you
take her
don't come any closer
i mean it
as he's escaping in the elevator he
bumps back into marlene who pleads with
him to reconsider instead he doubles
down on his decision by shooting marlene
before leaving the firefly's base in an
absolute state of carnage in the car
ellie comes too and joel feeds us some
absolute nonsense story about there
being a load of immune people like ellie
and that he's decided to take them home
to tommy's settlement i told you this
was a big day for the franchise's
history and to be honest i've only
really told you half of what happened
across this intense day for the other
half we're gonna have to rewind
earlier that day we catch up with
someone new to our timeline a young
firefly called abby anderson she's out
trying to find her dad jerry who's gone
off looking for a pregnant zebra of all
things yeah you heard that right they
eventually find the poor lass caught up
in some barbed wire and help set her
free but more importantly they bump into
another firefly called owen who hastily
tells them that some infected girl has
arrived at the hospital and jerry a
senior firefly scientist needs to check
her out now she has an old bite mark on
her arm
no signs of infection they all head back
and jerry starts running tests on ellie
before concluding that the only way to
make a cure will kill her in the process
he informs marlene of this and she runs
off to give the bad news to joel flash
forwards once again to that pivotal
moment in the operating theatre and we
find out that jerry is the doctor that
joel shot down in cold blood and in the
wake of all this carnage abby eventually
discovers that her father has been
murdered by joel setting in motion a
particularly vicious grudge
as summer comes back around again ellie
and joel find themselves back at the
outskirts of jackson wyoming with only
joel's word for all the [ __ ] that went
on while she was unconscious at the
hospital in salt lake city ellie admits
to having a degree of survivor's guilt
over the whole matter joel the shifty
bastard consoles her and ellie takes him
at his word for now which i'm sure won't
come back to bite him in the ass joel
does tell his brother tommy though as we
find out in the prologue of the last of
us part two jesus christ joel and while
shocked by the revelation he agrees to
take it to the grave instead of telling
her the truth joel scavenges a guitar
gifts it to ellie along with a song and
this charming if misjudged gesture ends
a pretty hectic summer for the pair
there you go
[Music]
a year later we catch up with our
central duo exploring the wyoming
wilderness on ellie's birthday of all
days joel has a little surprise in order
which ends up being a trip to the
wyoming museum of science and history
the pair bond like the good old times
putting hats on dinosaurs that is a hat
on a dinosaur cracking jokes sorry the
dinosaurs are busy right now what are
you doing
oh wait one of the dinosaurs is here and
even sharing a touching moment in the
cockpit of a spaceship i do okay
for all the horrific stuff that happens
in these games these heartfelt moments
really help balance things out meanwhile
abby and a group of ex-fireflies have
left salt lake city and headed west to
seattle to join the washington
liberation front or wlf for short we
catch up with abby and her partner owen
as they explore seattle's aquarium what
is this place
well clearly this is some sort of
theater but for uh fish and as they
explore the half-flooded building abby
confesses that she still wants to hunt
joel down even if all of her leads have
dried up spoilers but abby isn't the
kind of person to let that get to her
[Music]
fast forward another year and we're back
with joel ellie and tommy on the
outskirts of jackson on a routine sweep
of a hotel riddled with infected ellie
opens the wounds of two summers past
namely the truth behind what happened
while she was unconscious i had so many
questions for them joel carries on
telling porcupies but it's clear that
doubts are starting to seep in and as
these doubts continue to fester ellie
eventually returns to the hospital in
salt lake city later that year to
investigate for herself there she finds
clues to a particularly uncomfortable
truth and when joel comes looking for
her she demands he tell her what
happened making a vaccine
would have killed you
this news naturally hits her like a
truck and while she agrees to go back to
jackson with joel she tells him she
wants nothing to do with them anymore
[Music]
ah christmas in seattle what a wonderful
time of the year
for revenge
we're back at the aquarium with abby and
she reveals to owen who's no longer her
boyfriend but she finally has a lead to
joel through a rumor that his brother is
based out of a settlement in jackson
wyoming with the blessing of the wlf she
and a handful of ex-fireflies head off
to get payback on joel
and so we've finally reached the start
of the main narrative of the last of us
part two which takes place in snowy
wyoming here we find joel and ellie
fully settled into the community that
tommy talked about during the events of
the first game and we get to meet a
handful of new characters too for
starters there's jesse a young
wisecracking lad who's part of jackson's
recon lookout and then there's dina who
comes onto ellie at the winter dance and
the pair share a kiss under a metric ton
of soft lighting seriously this is the
post apocalypse how are they generating
this electricity their special moment is
cut short though by this homophobic lad
who asked them to please think of the
children joel breaks things up and when
he tries to talk to ellie she snaps at
him to mind his own business but later
that night ellie drops by to talk to
joel in a bid to reconcile their
relationship which is you know very nice
of her i'd likely still be fuming the
next day joel and tommy are sent out as
an early patrol to check out a sighting
of a horde of infected at a nearby ski
lodge meanwhile abby and her crew have
finally arrived at the jackson
settlement and are rightly quite
hesitant to attack such a large
community in the name of revenge abby on
the other hand isn't and she ventures
off in search of joel and lo and behold
bumps right into him when he saves her
from a ravenous horde of infected
overwhelmed by the sheer amount of
mushroom zombies the trio fall back to a
nearby mansion where the rest of the wlf
are lying in weight while all of that is
going down jesse ellie and dina are sent
out on separate patrols with jesse set
to replace joel and tommy's only they
never turn up at their rendezvous dina
and ellie get caught in a snowstorm and
have to take cover in a lads hideout
that's absolutely reeking of weed oh my
god
it's weed and getting high from all the
fumes proves to be a natural aphrodisiac
and they bed down for the night the next
morning they're found by jesse who tells
them that joel and tommy are missing
ellie races to find them and eventually
winds up at the mansion just in time for
well
this
please
please get up
yeah part two is not about to pull any
punches in the wake of joel's shocking
death a new revenge mission kicks off
well a couple actually first tommy
leaves jackson to find clues to the
whereabouts of abby and the wlf in the
direction of seattle but hot on his
heels as well are ellie and dina who
eventually make it to seattle a few
months later
now a lot happens in the summer of 2038
in the world of the last of us and to be
honest it's a bit all over the place as
we get to see the events of the next
three days from a couple of different
perspectives ellie's and abby's as ellie
and dina begin their investigations
around seattle they eventually stumble
onto a few clues to abby's whereabouts
but in the process they get jumped by a
huge swarm of infected and ellie's gas
mask a precaution against the contagious
spores breaks prompting the pair to take
refuge in an old theater while there
ellie reveals the truth of her immunity
to dina while dina announces that she's
pregnant don't worry it's not yours
the next day ellie heads out on a recon
to find more clues to abby and runs into
jessie who's come looking for her and
dina the pair survive an onslaught of
wlf soldiers and infected and eventually
make it back to their theatre hideout
using the theatre as a base of
operations ellie and jesse start
scouring seattle for abby's whereabouts
which eventually leads them to the
waterfront aquarium where owen is holed
up with his pregnant partner mel and in
yet another shocking moment for the
franchise ellie in blind pursuit of abby
brutally murders both of them unaware of
mel's pregnancy damn this franchise can
be super grim when it wants to be at the
aquarium ellie and jesse bump into
joel's brother tommy and the trio head
back to the theatre and here not long
after the last shocking flash of
violence abby takes her swift revenge by
shooting jessie in the head and holding
tommy and ellie at gunpoint and now it's
time to go back and witness these
horrible three days all over again but
from abby's point of view
right now with abby we get to learn a
little bit more about a character that
is effectively the main antagonist for
the first half of the game abby is a
high-ranking soldier in the wlf which
itself is a sort of militia at war with
a group known as the serophites after a
routine patrol goes awol abby and her
colleagues manny and mel one and the
same as the doom pregnant lady we met at
the end of eli section managed to
survive an attack from seraphite
soldiers and make it back to their base
of operations within a sports stadium
here abby learns that the wlf is
planning a full-scale attack on the
seraphites island base off the coast of
seattle and she and manny are going to
lead it wanting to include owen on her
team abby heads off to find him at the
aquarium but is attacked by a group of
seraphites on the way here she's rescued
by a pair of seraphite outcasts called
yara and lev and the trio escape
although not unscathed as yara is
sporting a hideously broken arm yara and
lev take refuge in an office trailer
while abby continues on to owen's
aquarium they have a massive argument
which descends somewhat quickly into
makeup sex damn guys mel is very very
pregnant either way owen is done with
the wlf and tells abby about his and
mel's plans to leave for santa barbara
to sniff out rumors of a potential
firefly reunion no not that kind
abby leaves dejected and heads back to
yara and lev and with yara's condition
at a critical point abby has no choice
but to take her to the aquarium to
receive the urgent medical attention she
needs after securing the medical
supplies they need from a hospital on
the other side of town from the lair of
a cordyceps version of a rat king no
less yara's arm is all fixed up and by
all fixed up i mean cut off the next day
abby learns more about yara and lev's
history the reason that their outcast is
down to lev transitioning when he shaves
his head to look more like the male
soldiers it's a step too far for his
backwards community and it forces yara
and lev to go on the run for fear of
their own safety while abby is learning
all of this lev takes a boat and heads
back to his island home to confront his
mum abi and yara follow in pursuit and
while their journey is cut short by a
deadly sniper that turns out to be tommy
they finally make it to the seraphi
island they eventually catch up to
leviticus family home where he's had an
altercation with his mum and killed her
in self-defense yara comforts her
brother and the trio make to escape the
island you did nothing wrong but what do
you know that wlf attack is picking up
steam and yara meets her end when they
get jumped by a group of abbey's former
pals lev and abby make it off the island
by the skin of their teeth and row back
to the mainland while the seraphite
community burns to the ground
back at the aquarium they encounter even
more violence this time at the hands of
ellie yep they walk straight into the
aftermath of ellie's brutal murder of
both owen and mel while abby is
distraught with the senseless death of
her friends lev finds a clue that leads
them back to the theatre which just
about brings us back to
i don't know about you but i'm not sure
i can take much more death but let's
keep going right tommy pounces on abby
and for his heroics gets an arrow to the
knee and a bullet to the head and
seemingly dies then abby and ellie fight
it out for what feels like forever
seriously this is one long fight dina
eventually intervenes and as abby is
about to kill her lev shouts out for her
to bring a stop to the cycle of violence
abby heeds his words and the pair head
off leaving ellie and dina half dead on
the floor
and you know what i'll take half dead at
this point
all right flash forward another year and
we finally have something more hopeful
to latch on to
ellie and dina have finally made a happy
life for themselves on the most idyllic
looking farm in the known world
seriously look at how lovely this is hey
you know what
i'm gonna teach you how to play guitar
when your hands are bigger but this is
the last of us and naturally that piece
doesn't last you see tommy didn't die
and is popped by the farmhouse to give
ellie a heads up on a lead to abby's
whereabouts as tommy can't go on account
of his injuries he implores for ellie to
go and get revenge in his place this as
you can imagine doesn't go down all that
well with dina who just wants to be done
with all this revenge crap only ellie
can't let it go and she turns her back
on her family for the sake of her
history with joel
meanwhile abby and lev have made it to
santa barbara and are deep in their
search for news on any fireflies a dodgy
lead of theirs brings them to what they
think is the base of operations for a
firefly reunion no still not that kind
but actually leads them headfirst into a
trap
a few months later ellie makes it to
santa barbara and while she's following
abby and lev's trail she also falls into
a trap when she's released by a couple
of the same douches that captured abby
she learns if they're aware about after
she springs a counter-attack ellie
tracks abby down to a compound which is
basically a slave camp seriously are
there any good people left in this world
and she finds abby strung up on a beach
waiting for the high tide to drown her
and live ellie cuts abby down and
demands that they fight because we've
come this far i guess an emaciated abbey
naturally declines until ellie threatens
lev abby gives in and they resume their
epically long fight from earlier which
ends with abby half drowned in the
pacific ocean only for ellie to have a
change of heart at the 11th hour the
moral of this story is revenge won't
heal your wounds and abby takes this
moment of mercy and escapes into the
mist with leverboard a boat leaving our
anti-hero to lick her wounds
[Music]
all of which brings us to the
bittersweet epilogue of the last of us
part two ellie finally makes it back to
the farmhouse she shared with dina and
their child jj only to find it abandoned
she picks up the guitar that joel gifted
her way back when and starts strumming
it right into a flashback to her last
moments with joel the night before his
death and with her memories of joel
seemingly reconciled she puts his guitar
down and walks off into the distance
presumably in search of her estranged
family
and that friends is the last of us
timeline done and dusted well until they
announce part three if they ever do i
hope you enjoyed this video guys and if
you enjoy gaming timelines we've got a
load more on the channel including
metroid resident evil uncharted halo
loads of them so make sure to check
those out thanks a lot for watching guys
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you